all right watching the Democrat meltdown
over the weekend I have to confess it
was about as much fun as watching the
last Democrat debate you know you all
know by now that sanders handily won the
Nevada caucuses and to watch the
reaction you would have thought that
Donald Trump had just won re-election
Democratic candidates really are not
vetting Bernie Sanders Democrats need to
sober up and figure out what the hell
they're gonna do about that it's the
real winner last night I believe was
Putin we are living in the kind of
political equivalent of climate change
is extreme weather reading last night
about the fall of France in the summer
of 1940 and the general right now calls
up Churchill and says it's over the
thrill is definitely not running up that
leg tonight and what did they think
though was gonna happen did they really
believe that stoking radicalism on
college campuses and fueling this
general mindset you've all felt it seen
it heard it a victimization and they
thought all that was gonna lead to good
outcomes for their party for our society
they really believed that celebrating a
deeply dark and cynical view of America
and our pop culture was gonna end well
and what do they think was going to
happen when they stood by and nodded
approvingly as our young people were
pummeled with a message that our country
is racist sexist xenophobic and just
plain rotten well guess what over time
and in the absence of actual facts maybe
parents that teach the truth the
poisonous plant of radicalism will take
root the truth is that a nation which in
many ways was created and I'm sorry to
have to say this from way back on racist
principles when I talk about creating an
America that works for all people it
means doing away with the the systematic
the the systemic racism that exists from
coast-to-coast is America great in many
ways we are in some ways very
significant ways we're not so why would
like for instance new citizens unaware
of the left's ongoing in dock
nee-chan our culture in our school
sometimes even churches why would they
think socialism was all that bad the
Democrats couldn't even stand let alone
a plot I almost forgot this when at last
year's State of the Union speech the
president said this America will never
be a socialist country well one of the
Democrats in that audience did not stand
now most schools today
don't tell them the truth the students
the truth about life under socialism
that it always leads to less power for
the individual less prosperity for the
individual less freedom for the average
citizen the bottom line is Democrats
have no one to blame but themselves for
the Bernie juggernaut and even though so
many claim that Obama was such a
moderate he bears some of the
responsibility too if you've got a
business that you didn't build that I
believe in American exceptionalism just
as I suspect that the Brits believe in
British exceptionalism and the Greeks
believe in Greek exceptionalism we'll
just all agree to be exceptional
together now this is exactly what
Sanders of course a dirty millionaire
himself believes you know what mr.
Bloomberg wasn't you who made all that
money maybe your workers played some
role in that as well to share the
benefits also he didn't build that well
with Biden faltering we at the angle
knew that Democrats would hurdle toward
this radical alternative because if they
were going to go for like an old white
guy these new revolutionaries weren't
about to throw it in with old boring old
Biden they're gonna do that why go for
the incremental stuff no way they want
free stuff and they want it now and they
don't want to hear anything about
compromise or how you used to work with
the Republicans just about a year ago
when so many were laughing off Alexander
Ocasio cortes inter-gang I was actually
taking them very seriously as a
political force while others have
laughed at AOC and her sister and
socialism Rasheeda claimed
I think they're the legitimate thought
leaders of the Democrat Party the new
socialist maybe inexperienced but
they're bold they're energetic and
they're determined to shake up their
establishment now I take them at their
word sorry to say it but see I told you
so
and by the way didn't take long did it
for Speaker Pelosi to start catering to
the squad let's remember the entire
impeachment fiasco was spurred really by
their demands to remove President Trump
from office they promised their
constituents impeachment and they
delivered and who's more exciting by the
way and the Democrats sainted a Buddha
judge mr. perfect Klobuchar the late
comer billionaire Bloomberg not a chance
come on we don't know this in a way
Sanders is just a lot more honest than
Obama and his crowd and I love how they
pretend that Bernie's somehow not a
logical outgrowth of what came before
have we not forgotten who Obama's
spiritual mentor was the government
gives him the drugs bills bigger prisons
this is a three-strike law and then
wants us to sing god bless america no no
no not god bless america
god damn
[Music]
[Applause]
for the past 24 hours mainline Democrats
desperate to derail the Bernie Express
have been circulating his most recent
comments about Cuba
we're very opposed to the authoritarian
nature of Cuba but you know it's unfair
to simply say everything is bad when
Fidel Castro came into office you know
what he did he had a massive literacy
program is that a bad thing well wait a
minute where if I heard something like
that before
Cuba has an extraordinary resource a
system of education which values every
boy and every girl and in recent years
the Cuban government has begun to open
up to the world and to open up more
space for that talent to thrive
so today's supposedly more moderate
Democrats they don't want you to know
this but they're a heck of a lot closer
ideologically to Sanders then they want
you to let on they love calling
themselves all of them global citizens
since they believe America really isn't
any better than any other country
certainly not our Constitution not our
flag not our Declaration of Independence
not even our patriotic music that's kind
of passe isn't it and a lot of our
monuments tear those down how can a
nation that elected Donald Trump claimed
to be exceptional after all the
Democrats had a chance to put down the
Bernie rebellion years ago frankly
decades ago but they decided to ride the
socialist wave even Hillary never really
attacked his ideas is dangerous and
wrong Democrats this time around have
basically played pattycake with him as
well he's only gotten stronger you see
it and he's gotten more dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
very much so dr. Frankenstein you
created this monster good luck
controlling him and that's the angle